an animated declaration of love
to monsieur hublot
a lonely bachelor whose daily existence
is organized down to the very last
detail
it's a world where everything is still
steam powered
where everything is mechanized there's
nothing organic in this world
it's all metal or leather
the challenge was to bring a bit of life
into this universe
it's the first time alexandra espiga has
directed a movie
he usually turns drawings into moving
images
and he's done animation work on such
international productions as happy feet
too
and star wars the clone wars tv series
as well as for the hollywood blockbuster
iron man 3.
i like the look from the start
i didn't know
as a character
he was only half baked when i came into
the project
so it wasn't so much his personality i
was drawn to at first as the world
itself
that world was created by the small salt
productions in luxembourg it's
specialized in 3d animation since 2007.
the group is currently working on a film
about an alien called wilfred whom a
computer program sends to earth by
accident
about a small mouse who has fantastic
adventures
but monsieur hublot is by far the
biggest and most successful production
for l'oreal vids
it started with a meeting with the
belgian sculptor stefano
i was already fascinated by his
characters i thought they told an
interesting story on paper and it would
be interesting to take it further with
animation
that was the beginning of the adventure
the adventure lasted three years and
involved some 50 people
every animated film begins with a
drawing and then each object is animated
individually to create a
three-dimensional image
these animated elements are then
combined to create a totality
animation means giving life to
characters
it's as if the animated characters were
real actors
you have to forget their 3d characters
are animated from paper and get the
impression they're alive
right in front of us
everyday life is also animated
and his life is changed forever by a
small whimpering dog
the 11 minute long short was a challenge
but not only in technical terms
the budget was 250 000 euros
that's a quarter fifth or a tenth of
what it would have taken to make the
film in optimal conditions
of course we had to struggle every day
to conclude the project
but it was worth it in the end
in march 2014 la rovitz and alexander
espigar were awarded the oscar for best
animated short film
when they called us up
i moved mechanically
that was probably the most
me
i got it mechanically took the oscar
speech
and then i looked at the stopwatch
and when 45 seconds had elapsed i said
it's time to leave the stage
the story of a man whose life is turned
upside down in 11 minutes has delighted
festival audiences around the world
earning the film not only in oscar but
countless other awards as well